President Trump is pushing harder to
investigate the investigators who
started the Russia probe he put out a
memo last night giving sweeping new
power to his Attorney General who is
carrying out his repeated request for an
investigation Paula Reid is at the White
House with more on this story Paula good
morning to you
a good morning Gail Attorney General
William Bar has already demonstrated his
willingness to do the president's
political bidding and now he will have
the unprecedented authority to select
information to declassify and that gives
him the power to control the narrative
around the origins of the Russia
investigation this is all nonsense House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler slammed the investigation into
the origins of the Russia probe there
was no basis whatsoever to believe that
anybody in the intelligence community
did anything wrong in terms of starting
the investigation the president doesn't
see it that way
a phony investigation based on no facts
based on an overthrow of the president
in a memo late Thursday the White House
announced William Bar can bypass
agencies who usually control whether
their secrets are made public bar will
now decide what the public learns about
the origins of the investigation it's
yet another escalation as the war of
words between President Trump and
Speaker Nancy Pelosi reached a fever
pitch Thursday I wish that his family or
his administration or his staff would
have an intervention crazy Nancy his
master of distraction we will all agree
on that she's lost it the president
lobbed insults at his Democratic rivals
while standing in front of a group of
farmers as he announced 16 billion
dollars in aid for farms that have been
hurt by his so far unsuccessful trade
war with China I'm an extremely stable
genius speaker Pelosi shot back in a
tweet when the extremely stable genius
starts acting more presidential I'll be
happy to work with him on infrastructure
trade and other issues facing a
stalemate at home the president is
heading abroad to Japan and a friendlier
audience the Prime Minister Abbey said
to me very specifically you are the
guest of honor there's only one guest of
honor the president heads to Tokyo later
today but this
trip is more ceremony than substance on
the agenda a state banquet front-row
seats at a sumo wrestling match and a
trip to a u.s. naval base to honor the
troops for Memorial Day Anthony
Paula thank you